um we're actually going to find out that
not only should the Ten Commandments not
be in school but prayer shouldn't be in
school now we're go see because a lot of
the framework for how we've understood
how America should be has been through
received wisdom mhm and the Constitution
is very clear on matters and this is why
uh there was always supposed to be
proper Christian education because how
in the world can a public school run by
the state properly teach morality and
this is why having the church you know
properly spiritual and educating the
children you know people who wanted
their children to be raised that way
wouldn't have to worry about all the
immorality and all the sexual stuff
happening in the schools where they
could just have this one sphere where
it's proper and they don't have to worry
about all those nefarious you know
elements